mit einer paukenschlag forderung der
clan verteidiger begann der neunte
prozesstag gegen arafat abou chaker
seine brüder
das verfahren soll sofort per urteil
eingestellt oder hilfsweise ausgesetzt
werden
es geht dem anwalt um die durchsuchung
der privat- und geschäftsräume von abou
chaker am 22 september ging die
steuerfahndung bei einer großrazzia auch
in die arafat villa in kleinmachnow bei
berlin
dort seien laut dem anwalt verteidigungs
unterlagen beschlagnahmt worden
die durchsuchung sei eine inszenierung
unter den augen von funk und fernsehen
gewesen und die situation sei nicht
reparabel so der abou chaker anwalt in
dem prozess gegen den clan boss und vier
seiner brüder geht es um die trennung
von rapper bushido arafat abou chaker
forderte im jahr 2017 mehrere millionen
euro von ihm
als der aus dem gemeinsamen vertrag raus
wollte versuchte schwere räuberische
erpressung gefährliche körperverletzung
und freiheitsberaubung stehen auf der
anklageliste bushido sei eingesperrt mit
flaschen und einem stuhl beworfen worden
bushido selbst sagt als zeuge im prozess
allein in den letzten zehn jahren habe
arafat 9 millionen euro an ihm verdient
es geht also auch um mögliche
steuerhinterziehung in millionenhöhe
staatsanwaltschaft und nebenkläger
bushido wollen zudem verteidiger antrag
stellung nehmen danach müssen die
richter entscheiden wie es in dem
prozess weitergeht
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dir das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren